Pete good morning how are you feeling
no it's great hey one of the great
treats oh you know be pretty well over
seventy years or whatever we work
together is Game seven of the World
Series it's like the best day of the
year for me hey whatever happened
doesn't happen that often but when it
happens and I found this to be such a
compelling series and it our Series
between two cities I mean I can almost I
think I can make the argument that it
may be more important to the Indians and
Cleveland that is so the Cubs in Chicago
just because you know the Cubs are going
to be there for several years I mean the
Indians are still 28 and the major
leagues in attendance and the city is
down to three hundred and seventy
thousand people I think that having
LeBron and and the Indians win in one
year right just an incredible amount
from downtown Cleveland
we'd like to attach pressure who's got
more pressure and I don't know if you
know is it 60/40 5149 fifty-fifty who
who do you think has more pressure
tonight if either team does well you
know I I was just thinking about that
this morning about how it goes back and
forth per game I thought that there was
a lot of pressure on the Cubs when they
went back home and everybody expected oh
no it's gonna be great we're gonna win
here and then last night I really felt
that the Indians on the verge of
clinching really played up tight I mean
they're not only the defensive mistakes
but some of the bats were were unusual I
thought a little bit under supplement
and I think I really felt they sort of
felt it the feeling included because it
really was wild here yesterday and then
now tonight you know it's it look that's
what the summit games is so great that
there's not really any difference in
pressure they're just they're both okay
we go out we win you know it's there's
no sort of
well we're supposed to win on either
team and I think it makes it what makes
for a lot of fun and the two I think
that that for the Cubs they're so young
that all the sudden is very special and
they have a lot of players on that team
who are young who are high draft choices
who are very talented who really get
what it means to be here and I think the
Indians is a team really understand like
I mean it's it may have only been about
68 years as opposed to 108 years but
it's still so incredible for Cleveland
that it's any Indians it's I all of a
sudden there's nothing to loosely the
team I did and I think it'll make for a
lot of fun tonight and considering how
warm it is and you take ballpark factors
Cleveland is one of the top offensive
parks in baseball this year instead of
it being treated to like it was listen
wind was blowing in and regularly maybe
it's going to end up like a 7 2 6 8 a 7
game and we're gonna end up with 13
pitchers in the game I don't know well I
was also speaking of pitchers with what
happened with Joe Maddon and Aroldis
Chapman we know what the end result was
but in the moment what did you make of
that move and to have Chapman come out
and pitch the 9th inning when you have
such a big lead except I was I was
surprised by Joe obviously doesn't think
that Chapman's going to be affected by
having pitched the day before and I am
you know if we can all sing along with
Warren Zevon so simple and dead and so I
was surprised he came out for the night
I thought he could have said that yeah
send the trainer to the mound and say
his ankle bothering him and and go get
somebody else but I also understand
Joe's looking at what the Indians have
done this year and they've got 38
come-from-behind wins at home at 58 and
53 and 28 at home in the regular season
and they had 38 come-from-behind wins I
get it and I think it was
I can't remember the number of laughs
and bad winds walk off but I think
there's a there's a fear don't let them
back Inglot don't but let's just hold
this game and we'll figure all we do
tomorrow it's almost like Jim Valvano
you know just surviving yeah and move on
and I think that's the way he was
looking at and is it yeah it was easier
for Tony Francona because I mean that
there was no need to crank Miller and
and and Ellen out there but in Joe's
case you know you there is this make
sure that there's a smile and go from
there and then wherever a wall this
Chapman is next April he can go out and
make his exit parents who should be
favored tonight
I think the Indians because Kluber has
been so great in his India starts in the
postseason and he's thrown so few
pitches he's only averaged 92 pitches
per start in the postseason only 84 and
he's in these three straight games with
three days rest so he could probably get
them 18 Nelson and get Miller and Alan
into the game pretty securely and I
think that gives them an advantage the
difference will be if besides being 65
to 70 degrees and human the wind is
blowing out and it impacts Cleveland but
I don't think it will I think that I
think it's on the answer I think the
other thing is and I have great
admiration to Kyle Hendricks
but if he's only gonna go five where the
Cubs go will Leicester and Lackey hmm
how will they be in relief I mean
they're both extraordinary pictures
great money pitchers but I was referring
so they're both fussy and I'm not sure
relief pitchers can be fussy and I'll be
very interested to see what they do out
of the paper it's so if they have to
pitch the sixth and seventh innings they
maybe bring it but on the other hand
maybe they are and maybe
Chapman isn't quite what he has been at
certain times I mean his Lawson was down
a little bit last night he was up to 101
right before but on Sunday night but
this is something I think there a
bullpen situation because of stroke and
Rondon being so ineffective really
reason with the difficulties of trying
to plow through the 7th 6th 7th and 8th
innings
we'll have fun tonight Pete great to
talk to you thanks for joining us
I certainly will that's Peter Gammons
all of Famer MLB Network broadcaster
analyst the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience